bonsoir francis lalanne merci de
répondre à nos questions directes sur
sur rt france met donc les luttes que
j'ai entendu ce que vous avez dit
pardonnez moi t'es pas tout à fait
d'actes en fait le conseil d'état a
reconnu qu'il ya des ruptures d'égalité
il a reconnu que le gouvernement
n'aurait jamais dû fermer des théâtres
la manière dont il a fait mais il veut
justement le signe d'espoir non il veut
pas anticiper la réouverture par rapport
à être été fixé par le gouvernement
même si le conseil d'état déplore
finalement à cette rupture d'égalité et
des abus il n'a pas prononcé comme ça
mais ce qu'on appelle en droit une
erreur manifeste d'appréciation du
gouvernement donc c'est vachement bien
parce que ça veut dire qu'il faut plus
quitte à lui d'attaquer maintenant on
est quand même le point de vue du
conseil d'état qui est qui est
défavorable à la rupture d'égalité est
d'ailleurs tout à fait normal voilà on
se souvient le 15 décembre
quand jean castex a pris la parole pour
dire les lieux culturels restent fermés
on se souvient de jean michel ribes le
patron du théâtre du rond point à paris
qui avait dit j'ai vu des comédiens
pleurer ce soir dans quel état d'esprit
sont les acteurs de la culture nous
parce qu'il ya des larmes ou est ce
qu'il ya des sourires comme vous évoquez
justement ce motif d'espoir devait nous
on est des gens d'émotion on pleure on
rit mais on pense avant tout au public
et ont finalement on aimerait dire moque
un peu le moral des gens en les tenant
un petit peu rêver en faisant notre
travail jean castex que moi
personnellement j'appelle jean kft wa lâ
ilâha illâ a conquis un acte totalement
anti républicain et il a outrepassé les
pouvoirs que lui donne la réplique est
on avec lui avec ses décisions les plus
dans l'état de droit là le conseil
d'état a finalement il a rappelé qu'on
était encore dans un état de droit alors
est un petit peu décevant le conseil
d'état a manqué d'audace mais quand même
ouais il aurais tu manques de courage
car si toi la wii est une décision
politique est opportune et opportuniste
à dire et pas une décision juridique qui
le président est-il le conseil d'état et
le président du conseil d'état avait
pris une décision juridique en
reconnaissant la rupture d'égalité il
aurait bien évidemment dit que le
gouvernement a c'est une erreur
manifeste d'appréciation et donc aux
orcs et retoqué le gouvernement dans sa
décision de fermer des théâtres c'est
d'une certaine manière il lassé il a
passé d'une manière audacieuse il là il
n'a pas eu le courage d'affronter le
gouvernement qui est dommage et je le
déplore t il a quand même dit le droit
il a dit qu'on n'a pas le droit
d'établir des dix crimes des
discriminations dans le cadre d'un
programme exceptionnel
il fallait le pour un dictionnaire il
faut pas qu'elle soit le fait du prince
ça doit être limitée dans le par le
cadre de la loi
ça peut pas être subjectif et en
l'occurrence le gouvernement n'a
toujours pas apporté la preuve que les
chiffres qu'il donne sont réelles et il
n'a toujours pas apporté la preuve vous
accusé le gouvernement de mentir je
j'accuse le gouvernement de la vérité
c'est-à-dire de ne pas avoir apporté des
preuves de ce qu'il avance et il nous a
toujours pas apporté la preuve que
devant un fromage et n'est pas
contagieuse
alors qu'une queue devant un théâtre est
contagieuse il nous a pas apporté la
preuve que des gens confiner les uns sur
les autres dans un wagon enfin ce qui
est un espace à plus haut et le projet
et est restreint il nous a toujours pas
apporté la preuve que des gens assis les
uns sur les autres parce qu'on a
supprimé des trains au lieu de rajouter
des tracts si on veut séparer les gens
dans un wagon on veut qu'ils aient un
fauteuil inoccupés entre sept fauteuils
occupés il faut rajouter des travaux pas
supprimer des trains mais le
gouvernement ne l'a toujours pas prouvé
que quand on était assis à côté d'une
personne dans un wagon n'était pas
contagieux et quand on est assis à deux
rangs d'une personne dans un pea qui est
un espace beaucoup plus important on est
contagieux donc le gouvernement n'a
d'ici le 7 janvier
comment le monde du
du spectacle de la culture va se faire
entendre alors est ce qu'il ya des
actions de prévu en rappel 27 janvier et
la date de valeur pour la clause de
revoyure elle a bien dit roselyne
bachelot la ministre de la culture c'est
pas le 7 janvier que sa mère ouvrir mais
on va on va évoquer une éventuelle
ouverture à écouter d'abord roselyne est
une personne très bien et je pense que
robin en a marre outils de cette
histoire et je pense qu'elle va pas
tarder à le manifester parce que c'est
le genre de dames qui sait dire non à
l'a prouvé dans le passé
donc j'attends beaucoup d'elle on attend
beaucoup d'elle on l'a pas du haut
conseil d'état
ça c'est un peu dommage il y avait un
petit avocat genre à tous nazis qui nous
expliquait que nous les artistes on
était des êtres inférieurs et donc ce
n'était pas grave on travaille pas bon
on en a vu d'autres mais ce jeudi on
aimerait bien que roselyne un petit peu
dit un petit peu de ce qu'elle ressent
parce que je suis sûr qu elle l est pas
contente avec cette histoire
malheureusement je vais dire quelque
chose je veux dire quelque chose
pourrait rapidement france est alors oui
oui oui les et on vous écoute oui dans
la halle dans le droit moi je voudrais
qu'on parle de droit 1-2 droit
républicain dans le droit il est clair
que la liberté qui prime
insatisfait du droit la liberté priment
est l'exception
ainsi doit y avoir une exception qui va
réduire les libertés fondamentales
elle doit être justifiée en l'occurrence
l'exception qui est fait sur le dans le
monde du théâtre et du cinéma et d'ici
n'est pas justifiée donc on n'est plus
dans le droit et on est plus dans le
pouvoir discrétionnaire on est dans la
vie de droit on est dans l'arbitraire
dans le fantasme est là où ils demandent
finalement de croire sur parole le
gouvernement qui a dit n'importe quoi au
début de la pandémie qui continuent à
dire n'importe quoi maintenant
maintenant on nous explique qu'il faut
absolument qu'on fasse comme les autres
pays du monde
je rappelle que la france 1 n'est pas le
glissement de panurge et que la force de
son temps dans l'histoire a montré
l'exemple
donc on va pas commencer à régler les
affaires dans notre pays en font sens ce
sont les vôtres
donc tout ça n'est pas sérieux 1 tout ça
n'est pas sérieux
donc il ya eu une décision qui a été
prise de fermer les théâtres cette
décision est illégale
ça vient d'être dit par le conseil
d'état donc il ya deux choses sont à
retenir
la première c'est qu'il ne faut plus
jamais recommencer à faire ce truc là
la même si on attend ils les diables je
me permets de vous couper parce que la
plus haute juridiction valide quand même
la fermeture des cinémas et théâtres
dixit ne porte pas une atteinte
manifeste illégale aux libertés
fondamentales
non non pas du tout vous avez mal lu la
décision est saluée qu'il est difficile
à lire les décisions du conseil d'état
parce qu'en fait tout ce qui n'est pas à
rejeter la nuit voiliers mais on se sait
pas du tout ce que dit le conseil d'état
le côté détaillé qui a rupture d'égalité
d'accord mais il dit qu'en l'état actuel
de ce que le ministère de la santé
présente comme étant les chiffres
inquiétants de cette soi-disante en déni
il se sent pas d'anticiper la
réouverture des théâtres les il dit bien
que ils voulaient avec cette ordonnance
demain il est si freud est un directeur
de théâtre a au nom de cette ordonnance
est ouvert sans théâtre des clercs
droite
moi je ne suis pas content de la
décision de 2 du côté des tables et
quand même je reconnais que finalement
le conseil d'état eut un certain courage
malgré tout en rappelant que cette
diffusion est une décision illégale et
qu'elle quelle soit une rupture
d'égalité rupture d'égalité dans la
république ça n'existe pas enfin des
libertés de sa liberté subjectif mais
l'égalité c'est pas types d'actifs
merci l'égalité objectif donc
objectivement il ya rupture d'égalité
dans ce pays
objectivement on est en train de glisser
de la république vers le totalitarisme
merci francis lalanne d'avoir répondu à
nos questions et très bonnes fêtes de
fin d'année à vous quand même malgré ce
contexte difficile